you can imagine it's not super easy to
just buy bridge and build all this stuff
it's our American Dream not everybody
dreams of picket fences and houses we've
dreamt of a bridge bungy jumping gets
categorized is more of a carnival ride
but for me and my friend kind of our
sanctuary it's not fear it's just
happiness pure happiness
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Doug fructose there's four of
us they don't vertigo bungee we've been
friends a long time been jumping for
decades we met almost 30 years ago and
you know we've been bungee jumping ever
since the memories that we have together
are priceless
it's amazing that we've been friends
that long we have owned the Youngs high
bridge for six years and on the East
Coast we are pretty much the only ones
that jump from a bridge
bungee jumping from bridges is the best
way to do it
that's where bungy jumping came from
originally was from bridges and most
bridges have that scenic natural
environment which is a lot nicer than a
parking lot because we own this bridge
we've been able to create the perfect
environment for bungee jumping we have
the skill and the ability to make people
feel confident and comfortable you know
we love what we do we want to see
everybody jump and have a great time
yeah we'll get started and have fun we
get every single type of person you can
imagine up here you get people that came
out here thinking I'd never do this they
came up to watch their friend next thing
you know they're jumping off this bridge
three times you know it is a very safe
activity allows people to push their
limits when we're out here it puts you
in a place that's just focused on the
moment you're not thinking about bills
you're not thinking about relationships
you're not thinking about anything but
what's happening to you and what you're
seeing right from you I mean those
seconds they're slow seconds they seem
longer everything slows down it's a time
a short time but it is a time that I can
just focus on the moment
I don't I don't really ever want to stop
so if I can yeah I don't see a day that
I'm gonna stop bungee jumping I don't
think my partners will either we're
gonna jump as much as we can until we
can't anymore
coming up on 30 years and going on 40 or
50